separated the children those cages that
were shown I think they were very
inappropriate they were built by
President Obama's administration not by
Trump take a look the press knows it you
know it we all know it well within
moments of that about child separation
under Obama the media rushed to 44s
defense the president tried to falsely
blame Barack Obama for the policy which
is widely regarded as highly inhumane a
moment that showed some separation
between mr. Trump and the truth it is a
direct lie when the president blames the
Obama administration on separation we're
going to need a back-up generator for
the fact-check machine this is
interesting since in June of last year
even McClatchy Newspapers
had to admit this in a headline quote
yes Obama separated families at the
border too and then today and one of the
more remarkable admissions that I've
ever seen
Sam vinegar on who's a CNN national
security analyst and Obama alum said
this President Obama separated children
from their families wolf from adult
wealth it was for their protection it
was if there was a risk of trafficking
or other kind of harm that might have
been incurred that's what the Trump
folks are doing now if the child's
welfare is in jeopardy they have an
obligation to keep the child safe ever
heard of it well when Obama does it it's
good when Trump does it it's cruel
joining me now former House Speaker Newt
Gingrich Fox News contributor host of
the fabulous new podcast newts world mr.
speaker did the media all of a sudden
get Obama administration amnesia here no
it's not all of a sudden the media has
been operating for for three years on
the premise that if Donald Trump does
something is evil and if the same thing
is done by a Democrat it must have
really been good that's who they are
they're so obsessed with hating Trump
that they've lost all it's like someone
obsessed in a relationship like you've
you can't text someone 15 times every
five minutes that's bad but you lose all
sense of reality well that's like what
they're so obsessed with hating on Trump
that they can't remember what happened
three years ago well but I think you
have to start with that No
none of these people represent the news
media you could say that they represent
fake media you could represent that they
represent anti-trump propaganda but they
don't have any interest in the truth
they want to know what can they do today
to hit Donald Trump and that's their
whole lot method and it's in it's a
group think that is really pretty
astonishing we've we're very seldom in
our country's history seen the kind
groupthink that we now have in fact I
just did a newsletter in which I
compared it to the Salem Witchcraft
Trials and to to Savonarola and Florence
in the 15th century this high to the you
know the floods Allante in the Middle
Ages you suddenly have this wild pattern
sweep and people begin doing crazy
things because they're all doing it and
therefore they are speaking of burning
people at the stake this is what they're
doing now to people as they leave the
administration I want to show you what
it was tweeted today about Christian
Nielsen now this was Alexandra Castillo
Cortes tweeting retweeting the senior
writer for Rolling Stone Jamil Smith
Kristin Nielsen should be a pariah for
life no cable deals no Cushi college
gigs and what should happen to trump
foot soldiers who think they can escape
with their reputations intact simply
because they were following orders and
the the you know the favorite spokesman
for the Democrats today self-appointed
AOC says in stealing thousands of
children deporting their parents
refusing to provide info on Rena
fication Nielsen oversaw one of the
largest scale I don't know if that's
grammatical but largest scale human
rights violations in recent history
awarding her a lucrative deal participa
ste just post is to legitimize and
celebrate that abuse so they want to
make it toxic nude for anyone to be
connected with work for work for or
support any policies that Trump's ever
been associate you get the level of
hatred from these folks that Lincoln God
from the slave owners I mean you have a
level of just deep vitriolic hatred and
they think that anything they can do is
okay
because they're pure anything they do to
us is okay because we're bad Ilan Omar
said Steve's with Steven Miller at the
white house is a white nationalist he's
a Jewish American and she gets away with
that it's in the cover Newsweek yeah
well this is the person who today said
some people did some bad things at 9/11
and now I mean you can't describe who
did it or what they did it just tells
you how literally these people are being
brainwashed into a left-wing theological
position that had that's a frenzy the
cabinet for this administration a lot of
people aren't familiar with the names
and the personalities individuals but I
said earlier in the angle that here
these are really people have had really
successful lives direct comfortable
lives they come into this town they're
defamed they're maligned they're called
traitors treasonous national white
nationalist racist xenophobes and I'm
thinking they still they still show up
to work every day and they still fight
for this country you know might not
agree with everything they do but that's
okay but this is what it is it's not a
congressional oversight no it isn't this
is closer to an inquisition but I love
the moment today with Waters
congresswoman waters going after
Secretary minuchin and one intern
explaining he wasn't afraid of being
fired and I don't think secretary the
congressman waters has any idea how
wealthy minuchin is I mean waters might
be worried about getting fired
but shares she has no visible means of
support but minuchin will be fine and
just it's it's it's amazing to watch the
level of ignorance that the Democrats
are now displaying they're combining two
factors they're really ignorant and they
believe in really weird ideas but you
think about just what the Obama team did
when it came to the crush at the border
remember 2013 2014 2015
a the numbers started to spike the Obama
team said they're all they're gonna have
to go home he set his own benchmark with
the daca kids if if he came I think
after December 2013 you'd have to go
home that was Obama's immigration
priority but when things got crowded the
oh my god let's start releasing people
so they started releasing all these
people Newt right which helped lead to
this crisis but they built family
detention centers and Texas and Florida
put people in not Pennsylvania they ran
out of space and they just started
releasing people people don't realize
Obama had this crush too and he just
gave up and he's just decided I'm not
gonna fight this let him all go yeah and
of course I think the pillar rises every
time you do that you increase the number
of people who want to come here because
the word goes back home hey if you get
there they're gonna let you in and of
course the judges been one of the real
stories here as an attorney you
understand with a lady the number of
judges who are at the heart of our
immigration problem because of their
capricious involvement and telling us
what we can't do I think as should be a
major scandal it is I think it's like a
constitutional crisis that one district
court judge can imperil the entire
sovereignty of the United States of
America which is what happened again
yesterday and the day before it in San
Francisco another district court judge
and do it and doing it on national
security issues the Supreme Court is
gonna have to get involved new it's
great to see you good to see you